how's it going bros my name is food ha
so many awesome things have happened
right now I'm on my book tour it's very
busy but I have one day and I thought
I'll spend it to open all the birthday
gift that I got from you bros while
doing signings we also hit 40 million
bros during the signings and even though
we were outside in the cold it was
miserable everyone was cheering and it
was really cool to be with you bros
while we hit such an awesome milestone I
doubt that there's 40 million people
watching but I still think it's really
cool number to hit and I'm really proud
of it and I could not have done it
without you bros so without further ado
I'm gonna open you bros gifts cuz
there's a [ __ ] ton of them first of all
a duck oh it says it's for Edgar I know
you want this you went to Edgar you
stupid son of a [ __ ]
oh god I should have started trading him
long ago
next up a pug I guess this is for Edgar
- thanks a squeaky hamburger toy for
Edgar okay these two are awesome it's
Maya and Edgar mating clay it's so cute
you see Maya has only one eye - that's
awesome what the actual [ __ ] I'm sexy
and I know it I'm sexy and I know it pug
cub cut let's see oh it comes with a pug
Wow Desktop duck shoot
happy birthday Felix okay that's me it's
a crab oh look more pugs I really really
really need more pugs please send me
more pugs holy crap a giant bag full of
candy I hope none of it is poison polish
drink oh yes there was bros literally
coming from everywhere around the world
like Indonesia France [ __ ] it I [ __ ]
it up you wrote instructions on how to
open it I still [ __ ] huh well at least
now I have a fantasy right yeah Cheers
the [ __ ] is this
thank you a toilet coffee mug this will
go perfect with the drink you bros
gaming the [ __ ] is this awesome drawing
what
it's Edgar Anaya yes you know what we
call them in Sweden just fish yep
they're cold just wish my only mark
right here as if I need a moustache to
be manly that's just rude hey how's it
going for dammit oh yes Beverly okay
Russ you need to stop sending me candy
do you want me to get fat this is crispy
spit seaweed hot and spicy let's try
them out yes what oh I like a 8 out of 8
all in Dane Danish Danish potato chips
Yas PLAs don't stop the [ __ ] is this
what someone made a really sweet book
we'd like the history of watching my
channel that's really nice thank you
now where was I yes yes that is the best
thing do I look cool oh no wow now I
have two of them another pug mug another
another another one sculpt your own
boyfriend
what the [ __ ] will I do with this okay
I'm gonna seriously try this out this is
so cool a bro glass [ __ ] oh my god
happy birthday Felix and then another
pot another Punk Mike thank you and now
I can put my my pug mug on my pug glass
protector thing yes my room is such a
[ __ ] mess already
hey Edgar is eating the cake well this
is your first a really really funky
shirt
it's from in Asia well I gotta wear it's
risen from Indonesia
I can't believe Bros traveled all the
way to UK to meet me from Indonesia
thank you and giving me this funky shirt
when I go to the club I'll be wearing
this sari I'll be wearing this beautiful
painting on my own Edgar what about me
what about my paintings thank you I'm
really impressed by the talent of his
bros these are really incredible does it
look good ten out of ten thank you
here we go you can't see it but it's me
macaron Mac macarons yes that's that's
what you give people again stop fabulous
oh this is so sweet
the pugs have really taken over my
channel haven't they
what is this megaphone drinking hat
that's [ __ ] awesome idea whoever came
up with that hello testing testing am i
loud and obnoxious
this is the most annoying thing it's
fantastic thank you
oh yeah someone made this it's so cool I
remember I remember the person who gave
me this he's like I made this it's a
fish hat it's awesome I love it
all right tumblr are you ready these are
amazing these are handmade pokemons so
cool I know sure Mandor is here
somewhere
oh yeah someone gave me a ukulele and
it's fabulous
oh where a boom boom boom one lemon holy
cow there's so many items but I remember
one very particularly they told me Kurds
we created you an effigy and I was like
awesome I didn't know what that meant
but this is what that meant
I love the Barbies have hands isn't it
very creative
it's so cool I'm seriously I love this
take this will repel all the haters I
appreciate that thank you a pug pillow
which I can bring with me when I travel
amazing fan art seriously amazing fan
art so cool holy [ __ ]
so good I remember this one too it's so
cool I can't it's too big
holy cow I love the fabulous family
more pug mugs more pug mugs I long card
mugs all right all right all right Wow
okay I'm gonna take a break there
because I'm sweating balls can I just
say though
thank you bros so much not just for all
these gifts I'm so amazed by all the
handmade stuff and the humor and your
talent and all the letters are so sweet
and all the devotion just the fact that
you both travel travel stand in line for
hours just to meet me I really really
appreciate it I think it's it it's uh
it's crazy I never thought I would be a
person that anyone wouldn't care about
Oh God that sounded so depressing and
not in that plane I don't know I never
see myself in someone in the spotlight
but it it's amazing to have so many
people supporting you and who are just
so awesome and do all these things for
me I'm gonna stop before it gets too
emotional but thank you all so much and
even if you couldn't make it there I
mean if you just support my videos I
still appreciate it and that's all for
now as always stay awesome rush I'm
finding me an effigy that's or today
from the forest with with Barbie hats
and it says looking fabulous this is all
the stuff I got from yesterday the e36
is the person that I'm gonna meet you
ruin my life